[video game beeping]
[crash]
- OH, [bleep]!
[glass breaks]
WELL, TOOK CARE
OF THAT EYE SITUATION!
KIND OF GOT A LITTLE BLIND SPOT
FROM HERE TO HERE,
BUT HEY, SMALL PRICE TO PAY
FOR GOOD LOOKS.
- WHOA!
GOD DAMN, YOU DO LOOK GOOD!
YOU'RE JUST ABOUT PERFECT,
WOODY.
- "JUST ABOUT"?
WHAT DO YOU MEAN, "JUST ABOUT"?
- WELL, IF I HAD GODLIKE LIPS
AND EYES,
I WOULDN'T WANT THEM COMPETING
FOR REAL ESTATE
WITH MY OVERSIZED NOSE AND EARS.
I'D TAKE THOSE IN JUST A SMIDGE.
- ALL RIGHT, LET'S G--
OH, OH! [grunts]
HEY, MALLOY, IF YOU'RE GONNA
PLAY WITH MY FROZEN HOOKERS,
AT LEAST PUT 'EM BACK!
[monitor beeping]
- IT'S TOUCH AND GO.
FOR 12 MINUTES,
HE WAS CLINICALLY DEAD.
[monitor flatlines]
AND HE'S DEAD, AGAIN.
[monitor beeping]
AND NOW, HE'S BACK.
- DO YOU THINK HE CAN MAKE IT TO
A FOREST OPENING AT 9:00 A.M.?
- YES, OF COURSE, THAT IS,
IF THE FOREST OPENING
IS IN HELL.
[phone rings]
WOODY, I'VE GOT
SOME REALLY BAD NEWS.
- SECOND WIND!
- UH, I'M GAY.
- COME ON, STEVEN,
THE NIGHT IS YO--
[retches]
[grunts]
HOLD ON.
[coughs] SOME OF THESE PILLS
ARE STILL INTACT.
ALLONS-Y, MON FRERE.
[screams]
- ALL RIGHT, WOODY.
LET'S GET A LOOK
AT YOUR BRAND NEW FACE.
AND, VOILA!
- HOLY CHRIST, MALLOY!
YOU WERE RIGHT!
I AM A GODDAMN ADONIS!